becoming the owner of your own home it's
the dream of many europeans
however since the 2007 subprime crisis
burst the housing bubble the dream has
become a nightmare for many families
spain was plunged into recession as a
result of overly risky mortgage loans
taken out for real estate in spain it
was very clear that it was a real estate
bubble uh their people got credits worth
much more than they could afford so in
the end of course they had to pay much
more money than it was anticipated and
also in many eastern european countries
they were very risky contracts for
example with different exchange rates in
different currencies and this really
made that during the crisis people had
to pay 25 30 50 more that was
anticipated and of course this would be
very difficult for them to avoid this
meps voted overwhelmingly in favor of
tighter regulation consumers will have
the right to standardize information
across the eu and will receive all they
need to know on the interest rate on
their loan they will also be given a
reflection period of seven days during
which time they may also pull out
mortgage credit defaults are on the rise
in the majority of eu countries in spain
the figure is three times higher than in
belgium where there are a series of
existing laws
this law would oblige member states to
impose sanctions in case of abuse by
financial institutions the task ahead is
to convince member states of the merits
of the directive